hace dos años que se trabaja en ello
pero los líderes de la unión europea
dicen que la invasión rusa de ucrania
encendió la alarma para un enfoque más
fuerte el lunes la unión europea aprobó
una nueva estrategia de seguridad
estableciendo una fuerza de reacción
rápida
que se desplegará en tiempos de crisis
creo que la adopción de este documento
envió una fuerte señal de unidad y
determinación
europeo se trata de crear un ejército
europeo los ejércitos europeos seguirán
existiendo cada estado miembro tiene su
propio ejército militar pero tenemos que
trabajar juntos más estrechamente but
with heart to war to get that closed los
ministros de la unión europea también
aprobaron una segunda ronda de
financiación de 500 millones de euros
para ayuda y armas a ucrania la fuerza
de cinco mil soldados que estará
operativa en 2025 tendrá componentes
terrestres aéreos y marítimos y podrá
ser enviada a entornos hostiles la nueva
estrategia de defensa conocida como la
brújula estratégica sustituirá a los
actuales grupos de combate europea que
existen desde 2007 pero que nunca se han
utilizado los trabajos para cambiar la
estrategia de defensa comenzaron antes
de la pandemia pero la caótica retirada
de eeuu y la otan de afganistán y ahora
la ofensiva rusa en ucrania impulsaron a
la unión europea de endurecerse la otan
ha proporcionado una sólida base para la
defensa europea durante años pero el
bloque se ha visto animado a impulsar su
propia capacidad de seguridad para
coordinarse con la organización el
pentágono confirmó el lunes que iovine y
el secretario de defensa a lloyd austin
llegarán a europa esta semana para
mantener conversaciones en la sede de la
otan en bruselas